hey it's me again in this video we're
going to talk about the good and bad
snack foods the first thing you need to
know is that if your metabolism is slow
there are certain snack foods that they
tell you that are good they're actually
bad so I'm going to go through what you
should snack on and what you should not
snack on one of the best snack foods
believe it or not would be peanut butter
now why because peanut butter has a
sugar of like one gram per serving size
so that's pretty low but make sure when
you buy peanut butter it does not have
added sugar so you have to really read
the label okay a bad snack food would be
fruit now even in my book I do recommend
fruit apples and things and berries but
a lot of people that will slow down
their weight loss fruit does not cause
weight gain but it can slow things down
because it's a bit too sweet so if
you're trying to look to improve things
just a little bit you may have to omit
the fruit from your diet until you hit
your ideal weight then add it back in
alright so then you could play around
with the amount so let's say for example
you eliminated all the bad things and
maybe you can get away with a little bit
of blue but a little bit of blueberries
or berries in your couch egg but some
people I need to remove that completely
to get them in fat burning just because
their system is so sensitive okay a good
snack food would be hummus why because
hummus has a zero sugar gram so we're
looking at the backhoe label and we're
looking at the sugar amounts one of the
bad snack foods would be those protein
bars because inevitably they have sugar
if you go to the store and you see all
those natural bars those meal
replacement bars a lot of those have
tremendous amounts of sugar okay so you
want to avoid that over here we can do
cheese cheese is a fermented food and
that means that the bacteria that helps
make the cheese in the fermented
process eats up all the milk sugar so
that should bring it down but over here
we have yogurt now again yogurts a
healthy thing of course the Sweden is
really bad but even the plane could have
up to 20 grams of sugar per cup it's
still too much now maybe there might be
some type of yogurt in a form of kefir
which is kefir it's a type of yogurt
that I did see on the market in some of
the stores that it has a lactose free so
you might want to read the back the
label and see if plain kefir would be an
option it may be it may not be I don't
know but the question is now what to put
the peanut butter the hummus on do you
put it on crackers do you put it on
Apple's well if you're trying to lose
weight you might have to bite the bullet
and put this on your favorite which is
celery which is very exciting right or
put the hummus you know maybe carrot
sticks carrots actually have very low
sugar even though they're a little bit
sweet so if you juice them they're going
to be sweet but if you have them as a
fibrous thing they're going to be okay
so you could take vegetables and dip
them in these things as well and then of
course cheese I like to take cheese and
tomato that's a really good thing but
not on the breads the grains okay so I
just wanted to give you I wanted to do
this video because so many people have a
little too much of this like their diet
is perfect but the snack foods are just
bumping them on a fat burning' just
enough to stop the results one less
thing I recommend the kale shake but if
the kale bloats you if anything bloats
you any bloating from any food and that
includes all the good things too like
the vegetables you're going to have to
either cook the vegetables or omit those
from the diet because the bloating will
stop your weight loss it's a key point
so if this is your situation and you
make the change it could be the
difference between losing weight and not
losing weight okay so I just wanted to
make a video and emphasize this one
point I'll see you the next video